this man's winning a lot um and he's
joining us right here on the rich eisen
show
as the nascar cup series playoffs kicks
off if you will or
i guess uh takes to the oval
at darlington uh on the sunday cookout
southern 500 at darlington raceway
can be seen on nbcsn with at 6 p.m
eastern time on sunday 5 p.m for the
coverage to begin
seven wins the second most in his career
he won eight in 2018 he's won
three of the last seven races he's kevin
harvick here on the rich island show how
are you kevin
i'm doing great guys thanks for having
me i am fine uh i'm thanks for thanks
for being on here
i i apologize actually though kevin
because i
i wouldn't have done that to a major
league baseball player which is talk
about wins and stats
and i just did that with you are you
superstitious like that
did i just do the wrong thing by talking
about the wins that you've
amassed so far this year not at all look
i
i when i got into this sport when i took
over for dale back in 2001
richard childress was the most
superstitious guy that you've ever met
in your whole life
it was 50 bills it was
green race cars it was peanut shells and
in 2006 we won in a car that had peanuts
all over it and i'm like
there is no reason to be superstitious
anymore just go do your job and
be done with it what do you mean by
peanuts and 50 bills
kevin walk me through what this what do
you mean by that
yeah so dale earnhardt thought that 50
bills were bad luck so he would not
carry them in his wallet
and richard childers the car owner for
dale and who was my car owner as well
when i started
uh he would not carry a 50 bill as well
so i i
you know he's the team owner so i bought
into the into the 50
bill okay and and apparently peanut
shells
broken peanut shells were bad luck as
well so if they were on the shop floor
you were in you were in big trouble so
um
it was uh those were the two things that
i learned really quick that i just
needed to get over and and
usually fast cars make up you know for
for things going bad
but i'm sure you can't look at a 50 bill
the same way anymore
pretty much i actually i i i honestly
i i don't see many 50 bills because you
know i just i don't use cash very much
anymore there you go
um but but when i when i do see a 50
bill i will not put it in my wallet to
this day just because
just just in case so does that mean we
might see venmo on the hood of a car of
yours very soon like the the venmo logo
look anytime i can flash my apple pay or
uh you know something at the machine i'm
i'm all in
kevin harvick here on the rich eisen
show to what uh
do you uh owe the win success that
you've had
uh in recent days and years yeah kevin
yeah so i you know i think when you look
at 2020 it's it's just a it's an
odd year you know obviously we all
understand the circumstances that we're
in from from the covet standpoint
and you know i think for for us it's
really kind of played into our hands
this year a little bit just because
of the experience that we have as a
group my crew chief and engineers and
organization we've all been together
going on seven years now
and we know each other and have a whole
lot of confidence in each other
as to what what each other is doing
whether it's me in the car
or my crew chief rodney childers
up on the pit box and making the calls
and or the engineering staff
putting the setups underneath the car it
you know it's just a group of guys that
have been together for a long time and
you know we've been fortunate to to
capitalize on
uh fast race cars that they bring to the
racetrack with no practice and no
qualifying and and
take them to victory lane uh seven times
this year so it's been it's been a great
season and it's been a great
relationship
over over the last seven years and
continues to evolve you've already
wanted darlington this year kevin what
do you like about the track
it's just you know for us it's one of
our most historic race tracks you know
darlington's been around for
60 some years and and you know i think
as you as you look at darlington it's
built around a pond so it has a really
weird
uh corner on one end because they
couldn't they didn't
they couldn't move the pond so they had
to make one end very narrow
and the other end's a lot a lot more
wide open uh as far as the radius of the
corner
um and it's the narrowest racetrack that
we go to so it's just a it's an oddball
shape uh racetrack that we go to that
has a very high
tire wear you know that goes with that
so from a driver's standpoint it's very
challenging because it's narrow
and the car drives different every lap
because of the the falloff and lap time
that you get with the tire wear
kevin harvick here on the rich eisen
show so um
you're the top seed in these playoffs
does that change the way that you
race i mean uh how does seating i guess
factor into
uh how you're gonna operate over the
next
races yeah so so basically uh what's
happened uh through our first 26 races
um you know you you accumulate points
that that go towards the postseason so
if you want a race you get five playoff
points if you win a stage in the race
you get one
playoff point and those accumulate
through the regular season to give
incentive to guys
throughout the year to try to win races
and do the things that it takes to
accumulate points now i get to carry
those points
into the last 10 weeks of the playoffs
and hopefully
we don't have to fall back on those
points but you never know because things
tend to get a little bit crazy with the
three races and then eliminate
four cars and three more races and
eliminate four cars so
hopefully we can use those bonus points
playoff points that we've accumulated
through the year
um you know to uh to be on our side and
make it to the championship race in
phoenix
and what a what a year man i mean again
not just the wins the number of wins but
sometimes the manner in which you
acquired them
uh at michigan you won both races on a
saturday and a sunday
the last driver to win nascar cup series
races on consecutive days was richard
petty in 1971 kevin
i mean that is a ridiculous stat that
you now are part of do you ever think
that you'd ever have a stack like that
associated with yours you know well you
know we've done
so many things this year that are so out
of character from from what we would
try to do as a sport right and you know
racing races back to back like you know
they did in
in the 70s and 60s and 50s and and you
know the things that that we've been
able to do this year but
anytime that you have yours any any type
of stat that is compared to richard
petty and richard petty alone
you know that things are going okay so
it's been uh
it's been a great year but it's also
been it's also been a you know just a
little bit of a
you know a trying year in a sense that
you know you don't you they don't let us
around
our pit crew guys and and you can't
share those wins with
the guys that are in there battling with
you every week and and trying to uh
um you know be a part of something that
that you can't be a part of
because of the fact that that we can't
be near each other because of covid so
it's been a it's been a strange
strange year it's been very successful
obviously that helps take a little bit
of the
the awkwardness away from you know uh
everything that covent has brought but
you know in the end we're able to do our
job and
you know we can't celebrate together but
someday we'll look back on this and talk
about
you know everything that we were able to
do in 2020 and the way that it changed
nascar
i heard that your son keelan wright has
now uh had made a go-kart debut
is that a true story at age seven
recently yeah so
yeah he did all right yeah so he uh
so covet has not only changed the way
that we race but it's changed
everything that that we do in our
personal life as well
um you know at the beginning of the year
we were we were not doing anything
like that and he came to me one day and
he said dad let's go
race carts and i'm like okay well let's
go race cars because we don't have
anything else to do right now so let's
let's figure out how we can do that
in our own little bubble and okay and
try to and and try to do
that so he has raced since uh uh the
middle of april
uh we've raced at least two or three
times a month and and that's kind of our
our family activity and school is is
done in front of a computer
yeah uh in in a room at home and and so
it's it's
it's uh you know it's changed everything
but i feel like we've we've adapted uh
you know well and and hopefully we can
we can keep adapting and this whole mess
will go away soon
is it is it is it true that he refuses
to race with half dollar coins in his
pocket kevin is that
is that true he hasn't caught he hasn't
caught on to the whole superstition
thing yet
maybe we can maybe we can steer clear of
that and we cannot uh corrupt his mind
we should leave it that way um you are
you you sir
are um i think you're about to turn 45
or you are 45 years old you're about to
turn 45 in december
and uh jimmy johnson as we know is that
age and is no longer
planning to uh race he's retiring or
he's gonna race but he's retiring
um what about you what about you with
your uh your career how are you viewing
it yeah
long haul yeah so you know look here's
here's the deal so i don't have to throw
a ball a long ways and i don't have to
run very fast and
you know i have to keep up with with the
things that uh you know i do from a
physical standpoint to
you know to stay in shape and and do the
things that i need to do and stay in the
car but they just they aren't to the
magnitude of what you need to be a good
nfl player or major league baseball
player or anything like that
and so in our sport um experience
you know plays a huge factor in the
things that that we do on a week to week
basis so
as we go through uh the seasons and and
for me i i tell
everybody i'm a late bloomer i've been
fortunate to find success
uh with with stuart haas racing over the
last seven years
and let's face it winning's fun i enjoy
being competitive and there's
there's nothing that beats winning and
you know i think as as i look at that
and i look at the group of guys that i
get to go in there and try to accomplish
that week in and week out
it's just fun my family's supportive and
and things are going well
and we're going to keep doing it as as
long as as long as i'm having fun at it
and we can we can maintain a good
personal life
at home so um right now you know we're
signed up through the end of 2023 and
we're going to keep racing hard and
having a good time doing it and in the
meantime your son just keeps getting
pole positions and uh
on go-kart races it's all good in the
hood for the whole harvick family that's
right
that's amazing exactly right amazing
thanks for the call kevin good luck this
weekend
on uh nbcsn 6 pm eastern time on sunday
uh
with the cookout southern 500 at
darlington
and um and good luck beyond that too all
right rich thanks for having me you got
it that's kevin harvick here on the rich
eisen show
that was a lot of fun hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here